HEY NO TOUCHY, science says I’m allowed
to have a stuffed animal.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Most of us had a thing growing up, a teddy
bear or maybe a baby blanket.
Something we held on to while we slept or
were scared.
But why do we love these inanimate things?
Science shows us why we place so much meaning
in objects.
Psychologist Donald Winnicott who was a prominent
member of the British Independent Group of
the British Psychoanalytical Society, introduced
the idea of a transitional object.
That these things help us transition in some
way.
They ease the separation between mother and
child.
Babies don’t see themselves as independent,
they believe they are one and the same as
their mother.
As the mother starts to separate this causes
anxiety in a child.
A bear or blanket helps them self soothe,
“I can’t have my mom right now, but I
have this, this helps.”
Or maybe these objects help us transition
from sleeping with our parents to sleeping
alone.
This theory has some evidence.
For instance, more kids tend to have attachment
objects in Western societies where kids sleep
alone earlier than in Eastern countries where
kids sleep with their parents through middle-childhood.
But why do we get so attached to things?
There’s an idea called called "essentialism,"-
We tend to think objects have an essence.
Something we add to them, like the same way
we wouldn’t wear the shirt of a murderer
or feel strange when standing in a place where
something bad happened.
Scientists put this to test with little kids.
A 2007 study published in the journal Cognition
had kids put their beloved object into a special
box that would “replicate” it.
When asked if they wanted the new, but identical
object, many kids refused.
Maybe it’s a kind of anthropomorphism at
work.
Some studies show that kids are natural anthropomorphizers,
meaning they believe almost everything can
think and feel like a person can.
In one study, from Bristol University, researchers
show young kids two pictures, one of a living
animal and one of a toy animal.
They told the kids stories in which the living
animals responded with a feeling and the toy
responded physically.
The kids were asked how would your toy respond?
Kids with no special attachment object or
whose object had no face, like a blanket,
said their toys would respond physically,
like the toy in the picture.
Kids whose special toy had a face, said it
would respond with thought and feelings.
When I was a kid I used to line my stuffed
animals on my bed to make sure none of them
felt left out.
I may or may not still snuggle with a stuffed
animal while I sleep.
Do you still have your stuffed animal or security
blanket too?
Feel a little weird about it?
Have no shame!
A 2012 study published in the Journal of Adult
Development showed that there’s no connection
between having a teddy bear and immaturity.
In fact, a lot of people still have attachments
to their beloved childhood objects.
A 2010 study in the Journal of Cognition and
Culture showed that many adults became stressed
when asked to cut up a picture of their stuffed
bear or blanket.
In fact, having one might be a good thing
for grown ups.
Separate studies out of Singapore and Amsterdam
have found evidence that touching a teddy
bear can ease feelings of social isolation,
fears of death and might even make you friendlier.
So do you still have your beloved childhood
toy?
You don’t have to lie!
Let us know in the comments below.
While you’re at it, hit those like and subscribe
buttons and keep coming back for new episodes
of DNews, every day of the week